It seems that nearly every small town has
one place you’re always told to avoid.
Maybe it’s an out of commission water tower,
or an old power plant that’s blocked off
with a large fence that your parents warned
you time and time again to never go anywhere
near.
But of course the words ‘Caution’, ‘Danger
of Death’ or ‘Private Property’ often
seem less like a warning and more like a challenge
to a bored kid living in a small town.
In this instance, the place beyond the chain
link fence you’re not supposed to cross
is a local radio station, a towering transmitter
that looks like a huge needle pointed at the
sky.
On those long walks home from school you were
always tempted to climb over the fence, just
to get a closer look at the tower.
If you were quick enough, you could dash back
over and no one would ever know.
Then, one day, you throw caution to the wind
and ignore all the warnings - because what’s
life without a little bit of adventure?
You cross the metal fence to go and investigate
the radio tower, but somehow the closer you
step, the further away it seems to be.
You walk and walk but still never get closer.
How much time has passed?
Has it been hours?
Days?
Even Months?
Before you know it, you’ve spent ten long
years walking in circles, trying every which
way just to visit the tower.
As it turns out, you probably should have
paid attention to all the warning signs.
Contained behind a perimeter fence is SCP-084,
or as it is known among Foundation staff - the
Static Tower.
Exactly what is transmitted from SCP-084 is
intriguing, but also highly disturbing.
Researchers working for the SCP Foundation
have found that they are unable to properly
examine the Static Tower, as anyone that gets
within a one hundred meter radius of SCP-084
suffers from various anomalous effects.
It seems that SCP-084 is able to transmit
a radio frequency, or possibly even a form
of radiation, of unknown origin.
This emission appears to have an adverse effect
on the space and time of the local area.
This distortion has a limited radius, only
reaching an active area that surrounds the
Static Tower in a dome shape.
Anything contained within this dome will both
witness and experience the alterations that
SCP-084 causes.
The most commonly occurring of SCP-084’s
different effects is that the tower appears
to teleport at random intervals, able to disappear
from one location and reappear at another.
Sometimes, the Static Tower will even appear
to materialize in several locations at once,
not staying quite as static as its nickname
would suggest.
It does seem to be limited to the field it
was discovered in, but wherever in that space
SCP-084 ‘jumps’ to, the dome-shaped active
area around it will also move, keeping the
tower at its center.
Due to the space and time warping effects
it emits, the Static Tower is impossible to
reach, either on foot or through the use of
any type of vehicle.
Any attempts to get close enough to examine
the tower have ended the same.
The space within the surrounding dome appears
to be unlimited, meaning that SCP-084 stays
at a relative distance, as if it is always
stuck on the horizon.
No matter how long someone travels towards
it - days, weeks, months or even years - the
Static Tower will remain out of reach.
One man that the Foundation encountered within
SCP-084’s area of effect, had apparently
been trying for six years to reach the tower,
traveling miles upon miles but never getting
any closer.
Additionally, the tower cannot be destroyed.
The Foundation has already attempted a number
of conventional methods of destruction, but
these have similarly never been able to reach
SCP-084.
Even if a projectile is launched from outside
the active area dome that surrounds the tower,
it will never hit its intended target.
The Static Tower can warp nearby space around
it, almost in self-defense.
Distances can randomly extend or contract,
causing the tower and its two small outbuildings
to suddenly teleport away in order to avoid
incoming damage.
During the Foundation’s lengthy and ongoing
observation of the Static Tower, a vast number
of anomalous occurrences have taken place.
Among those documented by the SCP Foundation’s
sentries and researchers, is the bizarre behavior
of any animals spotted nearby.
Very few can actually be found within the
active area dome, and any seen beyond the
dome’s threshold appear to instinctively
know to avoid it.
Any animals that do happen to appear within
the area surrounding SCP-084 will exhibit
very strange behavior.
Their movements shudder, or repeat in loops
like a gif.
These abnormalities suggest that they are
not real animals, but merely strange copies
with only a limited, repetitive pattern of
movement that ends when they disappear after
three to four hours.
Speech also seems to be affected when someone
is within the dome, with a number of reports
describing vocal communication being muffled
when inside the area around the Static Tower.
Other times, when people stand apart, their
voices begin to echo, with words usually being
heard several seconds after they are uttered
by a speaker, or even after they have stopped
speaking altogether.
Within the active area dome around the Static
Tower, the local environment also seems to
be affected by the tower’s anomalous properties.
Rain, snow, hail or sudden heatwaves will
occur seemingly at random, and usually the
weather within the dome is completely different
to that outside.
The sky will flicker and blur between different
states as well, shifting from day to night,
or clear to cloudy at a moment’s notice.
Additionally, no damage can be done to the
environment around SCP-084, even digging up
the ground will cause the earth to reset itself.
Situated near the field where SCP-084 can
be found, is a small township, however this
location is only visible to anyone that finds
themselves within the active dome around SCP-084.
It has been speculated that this town was
a part of the local area, and may have existed
before the Static Tower first manifested,
but that it has since become subjected to
the tower’s distortion of reality.
According to further investigations, the town
has an unchanging population.
Only three hundred and forty three people
reside there, no more and no less.
It appears that new births are impossible
and cannot occur within this town.
In much the same spirit, nobody living there
can die.
Any attempts at homicide result in ‘dead’
persons flickering before being returned to
life seconds after dying.
There have also been reports from this town
of events reversing, almost as if time rewinds.
This has most notably occurred when any town
resident suffers a fatal accident, or receives
an extreme wound of some kind.
When this happens, the affected individual
will be able to witness their injury visibly
freeze and then reverse itself.
Cuts close and bones reset all on their own.
People within the dome, like the residents
of the nearby town, will sometimes exhibit
spontaneous “blurring”, their arms, legs,
or heads shuddering violently at impossible
speeds.
Despite this being physically impossible without
injury, any subject seen blurring usually
remains unaware of this, and feels no pain
from the sudden gyration.
Much like the animals within the dome, human
beings will also get stuck in isolated time
loops, repeating simple actions without being
able to control themselves.
Someone might freeze after walking through
a door, flicker out of existence for a split
second, only to appear at their original starting
point and walk through the same door again.
According to the findings of Foundation researchers,
the town residents living within the vicinity
of SCP-084, no longer have basic human needs.
They don’t get hungry or starve, they cannot
be dehydrated, and don’t even sleep thanks
to being trapped within the Static Tower’s
area of effect.
At random moments, townsfolk will be able
to phase through solid matter, walking through
walls or phasing through floors.
This effect seems to last for brief periods
of time, but can often have catastrophic results.
Any passing through a surface or object when
this period ends, will often end up stuck
until the effect reoccurs.
Being unable to die, this does not kill these
individuals, and instead they end up painfully
fused with solid matter.
One person even found themselves trapped in
a wall from the waist down for two whole years.
Long term exposure to SCP-084 and its various
anomalous effects has caused the 343 residents
of the nearby town untold amounts of harm
and distress.
One can only dread to think of their collective
psychological state, having to live life in
an undetectable bubble.
Getting stuck in time loops, repeating mundane
actions over and over again.
Phasing through surfaces only to find themselves
stuck in place.
These unlucky souls have no means of reprieve
or means of escape.
All information regarding SCP-084 has to be
documented on paper, as electronic devices
such as cameras, phones, computers are unable
to properly function and record while inside
the Static Tower’s area of effect.
Any audio or video playback devices, such
as radios or camcorders, often detect bizarre
and unsettling transmissions.
It is unknown if these originate from the
tower itself though, or are just the result
of using electronics within the active area
surrounding it.
The dome that engulfs this town with SCP-084
at its center has left the area completely
isolated from the world.
It is because of this that there is little
the SCP Foundation can do to contain the Static
Tower, other than wait and watch.
Personnel are instructed not to attempt any
interaction with SCP-084, and instead the
tower has been placed under round the clock
surveillance to monitor any changes and observe
any anomalous effects it may cause.
The Foundation hopes to divert any unwanted
civilian attention away from the area.
There are no roads or publicly accessible
routes leading to SCP-084 or the nearby town,
and Foundation security will detain anyone
that somehow finds their way headed towards
the Static Tower.
Only with full permission of two O5 Council
members are researchers and other Foundation
personnel permitted to enter the dome.
Sentry teams provide additional security and
are stationed nearby within the tower’s
line of sight.
These units have to be near enough to see
the tower with their own eyes, as even viewing
SCP-084 through binoculars or telescopes makes
the tower appear fuzzy and out of focus.
All electronic devices, including radios,
televisions, cell phones, video or photo cameras,
Global Positioning Systems, are banned from
the vicinity of SCP-084.
This is done in the hopes of avoiding any
unwelcome interference from the tower’s
reality warping frequency.
Any civilian in the nearby area carrying any
of these devices or attempting to record SCP-084
by any means will have their electronics confiscated
and their recordings destroyed.
Given that no-one can get close enough, or
even examine it from a distance with binoculars
or other implements, there exists no detailed
description of what’s inside SCP-084.
All that is known about its physical makeup
is what can be seen from a distance… that
it is a solitary radio tower.
The SCP Foundation has, as of yet, also been
unable to determine the exact nature of what
is being transmitted by SCP-084.
Does the Static Tower send out a frequency
so powerful that it can warp space and time?
And if so, is the tower itself sentient, or
was it designed by someone for exactly this
purpose?
Whatever the answer is, we would recommend
keeping your distance from this hazardous
site.
Perhaps it would be best to abide by the warning
signs for the time being.
After all, you’d hate to wander too far
and not be able to make your way back.
Now check out “SCP-823 - Carnival of Horrors”
and “SCP-1730 - What Happened to Site-13?
The Full Story Compilation” for more diabolical
anomalous locations from SCP Explained!